hello and welcome to Python interview
questions my name is Richard Kirchner
with the simply learned team that's WW
simply learn comm get certified get
ahead
certainly the questions we're gonna ask
in here are very general with a few
specifics towards data science since
that's the main direction that pythons
going in and you'd want to expand your
questions for your interview depending
on the domain that you're using the
Python in specifically let's dive in and
get started with some Python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child 1
child 2 child 3 and so on and object 2
which has child 1 child 2 child 3 a deep
copy creates a different object and
populates it with the child objects of
the original object therefore changes in
the original object is not reflected in
the copy copy deep copy creates a deep
copy shallow copy creates a different
object and populates it with the
references of the child objects within
the original object therefore changes in
the original object is reflected in the
copy copy copy creates a shallow copy
and you can look at this if we make a
change to child 1 it's only a pointer so
if you make it an object 1 and a change
to child 1 and object 1 it will also
make that change in object 2 number 2
how is multi-threading achieved in
Python oh this is a good one with multi
processing and multi-threading this
question is actually asking you do you
know the difference between multi
processing and multi-threading and how
multi-threading works multi-threading
usually implies that multiple threads
are executed concurrently the Python
global interpreter lock doesn't allow
more than one thread to hold the Python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading and python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the Django
architecture so the Django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
Django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so when you
look at the architecture you can see
here we have a nice model
on out where the user initiates the
Django which initiates the URL which she
eights of you what they're going to view
and you have your model and your
template so the model of data whatever
data model you're pulling goes into the
template and then goes back up the
pipeline to the user and the important
thing to note is there's a template the
front end of the web page this is what
they're gonna see there's a model the
back end where the data is stored so you
can keep the template and the looks and
everything looks the same but you can
swap out the underlying information that
goes into that template then you have
your view which interacts with the model
and template and maps it to the URL and
then the Django serves the page to the
user so your Django grabs it and says
okay thank you for the URL and here you
go user what advantage does numpy array
have over a nested list so numpy is a
module you import almost always see
numpy important up B as in P numpy is
written in C such that all's
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module list on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore Python must
check the datatype of each element every
time it uses it this make number arrays
much faster than lists I would also add
in that numpy has a lot of additional
functionality that you don't have in
list there's a lot of things you can
automate in the numpy quick flip over to
our Jupiter notebook any IDE will work
if you're going to do a set of interview
questions taking a quick look at code is
always important we have our important
up B as in P we'll go an import time
here's our list list sub for eye enrage
of 100 and while we're doing is we're
going to time it so we're gonna create a
list then we're gonna create a numpy
zeroes array and you can see here look
how quickly you can create this number
zeroes array here we are appending one
zero at a time for a regular Python list
and here we are with numpy they're all
zeros and they're all of type integer I
please either float or integer on this
I'd have to actually do a type on it and
then so if we take in and we create ATL
one time equals time and then we do for
I and range of 100 for J and range of
100 L of I J equals L of IJ plus 5 so
we're just doing a simple calculation on
our array and sub arrays this is an
array of arrays I will do the same thing
with tal - tal -
timed up time till 1:00 so here we have
our final time on that and then we'll do
this with an array array op and this is
what I really love I equals a plus 10
and then you can just print it right out
so you can see right here with the numpy
array we're doing the same thing if I
run this our time is significantly
different here we have a point O 9 and
point 0 3 so you can see that the time
drops significantly when you're running
this on a number versus a list array
also important to note these times
aren't going to be they'll change each
time I run it depending on what I have
running in the background so there we go
number 5 what is pickling and unpicking
maces me how many times I pickle and
unpick 'el something converting a Python
object hierarchy to a byte stream is
called pickling pickling is also
referred to as serialization unpick link
converting a byte stream to a Python
object hierarchy is also called an
pickling and pickling is also referred
to as D serialization so if you just
created a neural network model you can
now save that model to your hard drive
pickle it and then you can unpick alit
to bring it back into another software
program or to use at a later time
how is memory managed in Python number 6
python has a private heap space where
stores all the objects the Python memory
manager manages various aspects of this
heap like sharing caching segmentation
and allocation the user has no control
over the heap only the Python
interpreter has the access you have a
nice little diagram here here's your
program
there's your interpreter we have our
heap memory management on the garbage
collector going off of there number 7
our arguments in Python pass by value or
by reference
arguments are passed in python by a
reference this means that any change
made within a function is reflected on
the original object so you can see here
def function of l l of 0 equals 3 l
equals 1 2 3 4 function l print l and
you're going to get 3 2 3 4 because we
passed l in there so it's a pointer here
we have def function l l equals 3 2 3 4
l equals 1 2 3 4 function of L print L
because in this function I have a sign
instead of operating on a piece of Elle
the list
I've consigned a whole new value to that
list or L then at that points we'll
create a new object so if I make changes
to the object it's going to change it in
the outside the definition if I use a
variable and I've cited a completely new
value like L equals 3 2 3 4 that will
not show up when you're outside the
function number 8
how would you generate random numbers in
Python to generate random numbers in
Python you must first import the random
module the random function generates a
random float value between 0 & 1 the
random range function generates a random
number within a given range and you can
see here one is lower n tends the upper
end and step 2 so it would be 1 3 5 and
so on as far as the options in the
random generation number 9 what does the
double forward slash operator do in
Python the forward slash operator
performs division and returns the
quotient in float for example 5 over 2
returns to point 5 to do a double
forward slash operator on the other hand
returns the quotient in integer for
example 5 double slash returns to 5/2
and you drop the point 5 number 10 what
does the is operator do the is operator
compares the ID of the two objects and
you can see in here where list 1 equals
brackets around 1 2 3 list 1 equals list
2 equals true and you have the double
equals in Python a course and you can do
list 1 is list 2 or list 2 equals 1 2 3
is false this too is not the brackets 1
2 3 it equals it but it's not the
brackets and if we do list 3 equals list
1 then list 1 is list 3 equals true
number 11 what is the purpose of path
statement the path statement is used
when there's a syntactic but not an
operational requirement for example the
program below prints a string ignoring
the spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learn we better two spaces
in it for I and variable so it goes
through each I if I equal space do
nothing else print I and then we'll have
the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
I does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need a placeholder for that
first logical set or that first area you
can also do a function like this you can
do function whatever your def function
name brackets colon pass so it goes into
the function and does nothing but it's a
placeholder number 12
how will you check all the characters in
a string are alphanumeric Python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in the
string or alpha numeric so you can see
here ABCD 1 2 3 is all number output
equals true and the second line ABCD the
@ symbol 1 2 3 the pound symbol is all
Noom output equals false so really just
want to know about is all new all
numerical alphanumerical number 12
how will you check if all characters in
a string are alphanumeric so here we go
if you know is all number which returns
that the characters in the string or
alphanumeric one can also use reg X
instead and said we have boolean re
match what's important about this is to
note your capital 8-2 capital Z a
lowercase - - - Z 0 to 9 means that that
array includes all of those the way they
have it written out plus a dollar sign
and then we have what we're comparing it
to the string we're compared to the ABCD
1 2 3 and so we can do an re match and
if it matches if all these things if all
the different entities in that array
match is the first one we're going to
now put true and if not an output false
number 13
how will you merge elements in a
sequence sequence there are three types
of sequences in Python
there's lists tuples and strings Python
of course makes this easy if we have a
list one and list two and list one is
square brackets 1 comma 2 comma 3 list 2
is 4 5 & 6 we can simply do list 1 +
list 2 and our output is 1 2 3 4 5 6 if
we have tuples your tuple is the curved
brackets designates it and again just
add them to
same thing with strings we have simply
learned s1 plus s2 equals simply learn
number 14 how will you remove all
leading whitespace in a string Python
provides the inbuilt function l strip to
remove all leading access from a string
and you can see here space bass bass
Python dot L strip leading strip Python
and you can also do strip which relieves
bleeding and ending the course there's
also the ending set number 15 how will
you replace all occurrences of a
substring with a new string the replace
function can be used with strings for
replacing a substring with a given
string syntax string dot replace old
comma new come account replace returns a
new string without modifying the
original string hey John how are you
John question mark replaced John with
capital Jo HN one and then you can see
right here hey John how are you and
since we designated with the one just
says we're only gonna replace one of
these 16 what is the difference between
del and remove brackets on lists del for
delete del removes all elements of a
list within a given range syntax del
lists start to end remove remove bracket
removes the first occurrence of a
particular character syntax lists remove
element and we see a nice example over
here if we delete the list 1 2 3 it will
delete the first in this case b12
doesn't do 3 remember that one - so
we'll delete B and C and you end up with
ad where if we do remove B from the list
and we have an ABB D it's only gonna
remove the first B number 17 how to
display the contents of text file in
reverse order open the file using the
open function store the contents of the
file into a list reverse the contents of
the list run a for loop to iterate
through the list number 18 differential
between append and extend a pin adds an
element to the end of the list you can
see right here we have a list 1 2 3 4
and we have pinned 4 and we end up with
an output 1 2 3 4 and extend adds an
element from an interval to the end of
the list and we have here list equals 1
2 3 lists extend 4 5 6 output is 1 2 3 4
5 6
so if you want to append an array to the
end of another array you want to use the
extend number 19 what's the output of
the below code justify your answer this
is a great interview question because
these are the kind of things that come
up and your proofing code def add to
list value and list so we have value in
and a list int or list equals an empty
in this case an empty list lists out a
pin value return list list 1 equals add
to list 1 this 2 equals add to list one
two three empty bracket list 3 equals
add to list a and then we want to print
dumb list 1 equals and you can see the
formatting we have a placeholder at
least one list2 and list3 so when a
prints list 1 we get 1 comma a and what
you wouldn't notice here is that list
one and list 3 are equal why are they
equal well when we passed the
information to the add to list we passed
value without passing the list equals
brackets without passing a second value
what this means is that list as we have
it if you don't have a list it will
start off with empty list which we
append the one to the second one list
two we appended a value to an empty list
so we only going to be one two three
doesn't matter what the list was before
we've already assigned an empty list and
then list three here's the tricky one
we're adding a to the list but because
we didn't designate the list list is a
shared value in other words it doesn't
reset it and we end up with list 1
equals list 3 1 comma a default this is
created only once during the function
and not during its call number 20 what
is the difference between a list and a
tuple lists are mutable while tuples are
immutable and you can see an example
down here where I have list equals 1 2 3
square brackets do note it's a list list
of 2 equals 4 and I printed out and I
have 1 to 4 if I do the same thing with
the tuple I get an error because you
can't change the tuple 1 2 3 into 1 2 4
you have to completely reassign tuple to
a new value what is doc string in Python
doc strings are used in providing
documentation to various Python modules
classes functions and
it's so you can see here we have deaf
for a function add a B and this is a doc
string we have the triple brackets on
there you can add carries return in that
so that you can go multiple lines and it
says this function adds two numbers and
then some a be return sum and so we have
down here two different ways of
accessing this function output accessing
duck string method one this function
adds two numbers accessing duck string
method to help unfunctional main this
function adds two numbers and so you can
see the code down here it has two very
different n values the second one is
basically a help menu there's our help
menu number 22 how do you use print
without the newline the solution to this
depends on the Python version you are
using and python version two you can do
print hi and then you had a comma
afterwards
print how are you and you have hi how
are you in version 3 print hi comma end
equals and it'll add a space on the end
there you can put different characters
in there but you just wanna put a space
to put a space on the end print how are
you and now we get hi how are you number
23 how do you use the split function in
Python the split function splits a
string into a number of strings based on
a specific delimiter so we have string
split delimiter comma max the maximum
number of splits the character based on
which the string is a split by default
is space so here we have an example we
have a variable red blue green orange
and we want to split it by commas and we
only want to do the first two so if we
print the list now you'll find it has
red blue and only spread it split it the
first two times and it gets to the third
one it just groups them all together
green and orange if you leave the two
off you'll split the whole thing number
24 is Python object oriented or
functional programming Python follows
object-oriented paradigm and you should
really know in depth what they mean by
object-oriented paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
Python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops
which as inheritance on a polymorphism
so you have an object and you can
all the traits of that object and then
add new traits in or alter some of those
traits
that's what object-oriented means Python
follows functional programming paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object Python supports lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes a variable number
of arguments here we have def function
name list so we can have in this case
whatever the list is def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and
then we can do for I and var print I so
if you send function of one you'll end
up with a one function one two five six
it'll actually print those out one at a
time the first one just prints out a
once it only sent one variable the
second one will print one under the line
25 and in line six number 26
what is asterisk args and asterisks
Korg's
args use in function prototype to accept
varying number of arguments it's an
interval object death function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if I send add the numbers a comma B
or a comma B comma C it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever I send to it
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic Korg's I can actually tell it
what I want to send so using a function
prototype and to accept varying number
of key worded arguments it's in both our
interval objects so you go through them
one at a time and the DEF function
chords you can now set like color equals
red units equal to so you'll see that
especially in machine learning there's a
lot of like they'll have in line equals
true that kind of thing number 27 in
Python functions are first class objects
what do you understand from this this
means I could return a function could be
one went from another function I could
create a function and treat it just like
an object I can assign it to a variable
I can pass them as arguments to other
functions
number 28 what is the output of print
neh underscore underscore name and
justify your answer the double
underscore named of
score is a special variable that holds
the name of the current module program
execution starts from main or a code
with zero indentation thus double
underscore name double underscore name
has a value double underscore main
double underscore in the above case if
the file is imported from another module
then double underscore name underscore
double underscore holds the name of this
module number 29 what is a numpy array
and we briefly touched numpy array
compared to a list early in processing
speed now we're just go ahead and look
at some of the more specifics a numpy
array is a grid of values all of the
same type so if there either all float
all integer all string and is indexed by
a tuple of non-negative integers the
number of dimensions is the rank of the
array and the shape of an array is a
tuple of integers giving the size of the
array along each dimension number 30
what is the difference between matrices
and arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways
now arrays an array is a sequence of
objects of similar data type an array
within another array forms a matrix like
we said here two-dimensional so if you
have an array of three by four that
would be a matrix number 31
how to get indexes of in maximum values
in a numpy array of course the first
thing to do is to import your numpy as
NP you don't necessarily have use NP but
that is the most standard use of numpy
we create our array equals an NP DeRay
of 1 2 3 4 5 and then if we want to get
our indexes of n maximum values in a
numpy array we can do one way to do it
is to take our array sort it then do
minus n : that means we're gonna do once
you've sorted it you can do minus n n
would equal then the number of indices
so it's not the actual letter n Kol it
and really this is about understanding
this notation that we can sort it so it
goes from lowest to biggest and then we
can get the top values for in indexes
and then we have our final set of
brackets with
- one on there number 32 how would you
obtain the resulting set from the train
set and the test set from below and
let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of 1 to 3 test set
equals numpy array of arrays we have 0 1
2 1 2 3 what's important here is it 1
it's a numpy so that leaves a out and
then we're stuck with 3 other options
and I'm gonna say the D is out and let's
look at NP concatenate vs. in P dot V
stack concatenate would put one set
after the other so you would end up with
probably give you an error because one
set is 1 2 3 and then we're going to
concatenate array 0 1 2 and 1 3 1 2 3
the array of arrays on to the end of
that what we really want to do is stack
in other ways you can actually switch
there's variables you can put in to
concatenate obviously they can change
this so you could use the concatenate
with a lot of fudging around but really
we're looking for is V stack V stands
for vertical versus the 8 stack which is
horizontal and if we do a V stack we can
simply do Train Set comment test set and
stack them together and so we have see
resulting set equals impede V stack
train stack test set both option a and B
would do horizontal stacking but we
would like to have the vertical stacking
option she does this again you could add
the axes in and use the concatenate to
stack at the correct way number 33 how
would you import a decision tree
classifier in SK learn we have SK learn
decision tree import decision tree
classifier from SK learn ensemble import
decision tree classifier and we look at
these they're all import decision tree
classifier that actually that last part
happens to be correct it's really just a
vocabulary knowing where is the decision
tree classifier stored what module is
that a part of and it is of course part
of the SK learn tree number see number
34 you have uploaded the data set in CSV
format on Google spreadsheet and shared
it publicly
how can you access this in Python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
you here but you can
actually number of ways to do this
what's important here is to know a
couple things one we have our link
generated from the Google Docs and
spreadsheets and then we can do a string
aiyyo aiyyo
requests get linked content so there's
our source and then finally we know that
pandas can read a CSV there's obviously
many ways through to CSV but data equals
PD read underscore CSV source number 35
what is the difference between the two
data series given below below we have DF
name and DF location colon comma
brackets around Astor surround name
comma where and then we have DF equals P
D data frame a a b b XX u u comma 21
1650 33 columns equal name and age so
let's take a look and see what they're
looking at we have just glancing at the
questions they want to know is that the
original data frame or is it the copy of
the data frame and you can see here that
one is view of the original data frame
and two is a copy the original data
frame two is a view of the original data
frame and one is a copy of there's no
data frame both are copies both are
views and if you're working with pandas
you know that unless you specifically on
certain things tell it to do it in line
and a lot of functions don't allow you
that you're always taking a slice and it
is always a copy so see both are copies
of the original data frame number 36 you
get the following error while trying to
read a file temp dot CSV using pandas
which of the following could correct it
so here's our error
trace back most recent call last file
input line 1 and module Unicode encode
error ASCII code X can't encode
character oh I hate it when that one
comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
the D doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is PDV csv has
our file compression equals gzip well
gzip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again not an encoding or coding setup
and then we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is Unicode that's
the most common - there goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
Unicode and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number C
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to sit aligned with any plot given below
so looking at this we have import map
plot library PI plot as p LT and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there PLT dot plot one two
three four plot equals show so this is a
little bit of a vocabulary test the
vocabulary is at width equals three line
width equals 3 LW equals 3 or something
else and the vocabulary word that we're
looking for is LW equals 3 which stands
for line width in pie plot library pie
plot number 38
how would you reset the index of a data
frame to a given list so this is a
vocabulary challenge and understanding
what re-indexing is re-indexing as we
have the different values here we have
the first one which has reset the index
well we're not really resetting the
index re-index number B means we're are
double checking our indexes to the
column into the main indexes so the
values matched correctly we're re-index
like now brings in a new index outside
of our data frame to a given list so
this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our key word
that it's external and we have a data
fit into a given list number 39 how can
you copy objects in Python the function
is used to copy objects in python we
have copy copy for shallow copying and
copy deep copying for deep copy number
40 what is the difference between range
and X range functions in Python well
this is a good one we have matrixes and
arrays with the matrix the range returns
a Python list object X range returns an
X range object and with arrays an X ray
returns an X range object X range create
values as you need them through yielding
the key here is that X range returns the
values as you need them so it actually
processes it post like if you have 4x
for a variable in X range is processing
them as you need them zero to nine it
doesn't create an array zero tonight it
just hands you zero than one two three
four one at a time number 41
how can you check whether a panda's data
frame is empty or not the tribute D F
dot empty is used to check whether a
panda's data frame is empty or not and
so you can simply create a we have done
here import our pandas as PD we create
our pandas dataframe equal to an empty
array and is D F dot empty comes out as
true one of the catches you got to
remember what these vocabularies is with
empty along with some other pandas set
up whether you need the brackets or not
at the end number forty to write the
code to sort an array in numpy by the n
minus one column this can be achieved
using Arg sort function let us take an
array X then to sort the n minus one
column the code will be x2 x2 : n minus
two args sort so let's see what that
code looks like we import numpy is NP
well create our array our numpy array
which is one two three zero five two two
three four so we have three different
entities with three different columns in
there and we go X of X and so we take X
of all the rows first into T well in
this case it's actually the second one
because it's 0 1 2 . argh sort so that
would be the second entity or minus 2
would also be the same you could also do
instead of one you could also do -2
there instead of the 1 argh sort and
then we get an output of the array one
two three zero five two two three four
number 43 how to create a series from a
list numpy array and dictionary so we'll
go ahead and input import our numpy or
pandas and have my list and you can see
here we have my list equals list of ABCD
of T or it all the way through so my
list now and makes a list of that for
array we have NPD a range to 26 my
dictionary will create a dictionary with
zip my list my arguments so I'll just
use the numpy array we just created with
my array to go into the dictionary and
the solution is simple with the pd
series my list PT series my
pd-2 had series my dictionary so it's
all about knowing the dot capital ser
IES don't forget that capitalization
number 44 how to get the items not
comment to both series a and series B
and you can see here we have citizens a
and B we have series one and two and we
have one two three four five four five
six seven eight the solution is we take
a Panda series we have series U equals a
panda series NP Union one dimension
series 1 series to so we can now make a
union of them we now have series one
panda series with an intersection and
then we can remove one from the other
series you is series you de is in series
one so if the Union is not in the
intersection then you know it's a unique
value a little bit logic going on there
and playing with three different terms
to get the answer we want 45 how to keep
only the top two most frequent values as
it is and replace everything else as
other in a series so again we're working
with pandas because if you're talking
series and data frames that means we're
working with pandas so we're gonna
import pandas as PD well go ahead and
create our pandas series we're gonna do
that by creating a numpy random random
state 100 so 100 and the numpy one and
then we have our pandas series you can
see here we're random integer no be
random two random integer 1 comma 5 by
12 and so the solution for this is we go
ahead and we've created a PD to remember
the capital S series solution we're
gonna print the top two frequencies and
that is our series dot value counts and
then we take series of values count dot
index of up to two so we're gonna take
everything up to two and then we'll do
the series is in so if it's not in the
first two then it's going to equal other
and this would be something you'd want
to write down on paper if you're if it
looks confusing take a moment pause the
video write this down
and see if you can figure out how the
logic came together and try to throw
yourself a couple other little logic
puzzles like this number 46
how to find the positions of numbers
that are multiples of three from a
series
and in here we're actually going to use
an upbeat of solvent the first part
series lets you know it's going to be a
panda series and if we come down here we
have NPR guerre so this is a vocabulary
question series with remember the
percentile three is a remainder so if
the remainder equals zero then we're
going to generate that string where the
object divided by three equals 0 has no
remainder so that we know it's both
below three number forty-seven how to
compute the Euclidean distance between
two series and this one's really cool
because we have our Panda series P and Q
and what I like about this one is to
give us two solutions you can go with
and really you should kind of know both
the first one would be yes you know what
the occlusion distance is and that is we
can take the first series minus the
second series squared and then sum them
up and then we do the square root which
is the same as taking the power to 0.5
doing the power to 0.5 is easier than
doing the square root so a lot of times
you'll see that as a switch but you
could have also done the square root and
use the math in there so there's
solution what you should know your
euclidean distance and then solution 2
is the numpy solution so we have NP lyn
algún or that's how we're gonna compute
our euclidean distance P minus Q very
elegant and very straightforward and
easy to compute number 48 how to reverse
the rows of data frame so here we have
our data frame we're gonna create a
numpy array by 25 reshape it 5-1
when this creates a 25 by 25 data frame
and so our solution is to do the DF I
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon minus 1 so we're taking all
the rows all the columns minus 1 so are
stepping minus 1 going the reverse
direction and then we're just going to
use across all the different columns on
there let me say that again the first
colon is gonna be your row starting row
stopping row step -1 that's all this is
about as that step minus 1 comma and
then all the columns 49 if you split
your data into train test splits is it
possible to over fit your model and the
answer is yes
is definitely possible one common
beginner mistake is retuning a model or
training new models with different
parameters after seeing his performance
on the test set my favorite example of
this is you have your script put
together and you keep hitting the rerun
button until you get the answer you want
not taking the answer it first gave you
or running it over an array and
recording all the answers to see how
they vary number 50 which Python library
is built on top of mat plot library and
pandas to ease data plotting the answer
this is Seaborn Seaborn is a data
visualization library in Python that
provides a high-level interface for
drawing statistical information to
informative graphs we've covered 50
different questions and make them up on
an interview hopefully you've taken the
time to note the vocabulary where you're
sticking and not having problems you
might have to go back and relook up V
stack versus eight stack versus
concatenate and also review the axes on
those little things like that also we
dress some logics how do you formulate
those different polls from a panda's
data frame so if you're looking at the
right data with the -1 step or an NP
array how we did brackets and really
fiddled with it I want to thank you for
visiting us today and joining us for
today's Python questions for interviews
again my name is Richard Kirchner with
the simply learned team for more
information visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
again thank you for visiting and happy
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here